Occurring between 1665 and 1666, the Great
Plague wasn’t exactly the first time London
had experienced such a terrifying spread of
disease, with periodic cases being reported
in the city for decades up to this point and,
of course, that time about two-thirds of China’s
population and then a decade later about half
of Europe’s, including an awful lot of people
from jolly old England, up and died during
the “Black Death”.
Nevertheless, the Great Plague was certainly
noteworthy.
According to the Bills of Mortality from the
year, in 1665 alone 68,596 deaths occurred
in London as a result of the plague.
However, it is generally thought that this
number is drastically under-recorded as the
likes of groups like Quakers did not report
their death tolls and many poor were simply
dumped in mass graves without their deaths
being recorded.
This latter point is particularly significant
as many of the more affluent city members
left London when the plague broke out, including
King Charles II and his entourage who left
the Lord Mayor of London, Sir John Lawrence,
to deal with the plague while the king and
court retired to Salisbury; they possibly
brought the plague with them in the process,
as it broke out there after they arrived.
Once this happened, the king and court retired
to Oxford to wait it all out.
In the end, somewhere between 25%-50% of the
population of London died as a result of the
plague during 1665-1666.
With everyone dropping like flies and nobody
knowing what was causing the plague in the
first place, this lead to some interesting
methods of preventing its spreading, as we’ll
get to in a moment.
So how did it all start?
Well, this was one of the many waves of the
bubonic plague that had been literally plaguing
much of the developed world for a few centuries
up to this point off and on.
We now know that the plague was generally
transmitted via fleas that carried strains
of Yersinia pestis microbes they had picked
up via rats.
As for this specific iteration of the plague
around London, the first recorded instance
was just outside of the city in a parish known
as “St Giles-in-the-Fields” sometime early
in the spring of 1665.
Soon after this, the number of reported cases
and the death toll rapidly increased until
it reached its peak in the summer of the same
year, during which thousands of Londoners
were dying each week.
In fact, the death rates became so severe
that daytime collection of bodies was banned
as those in charge feared a mass-panic if
people were to see the massive amount of bodies
being carted off by dead-cart drivers and
dumped into mass graves every day.
(One such mass-grave was found to house 1,114
bodies, being dug down until the grave diggers
hit the water table at about 25 feet.)
However, this daytime ban didn’t work out
at all because there were simply too few dead-cart
operators to keep up with carting away all
the bodies just at night.
As a result, it was common for people to stack
the bodies in the streets, rather than wait
for a dead-cart driver who had room on his
cart.
With rotting corpses literally piling up,
the ban on daytime collection was lifted.
As you can imagine from all this, fear ran
rampant and terrified Londoners tried anything
and everything possible to ward off the disease.
As mentioned, since the actual cause of the
plague was still a mystery at this point,
many of these preventative measures were either
useless or harmful in of themselves.
For instance, it was a common idea back then
that the plague was caused or at least facilitated
by “bad air”.
As a result, besides bonfires being kept burning
throughout the city at all times by order
of the authorities and homes also having their
fires going day and night, regardless of outside
temperature, many took to smoking tobacco
as a way of keeping the air going into their
lungs free of disease.
This led to a rather surreal situation in
which people of all ages, including children,
were essentially forced to smoke (or start
smoking if they hadn’t previously).
For instance, AJ Bell wrote a few decades
after the plague,
For personal disinfections nothing enjoyed
such favour as tobacco; the belief in it was
widespread, and even children were made to
light up a reaf in pipes.
Thomas Hearnes remembers one Tom Rogers telling
him that when he was a scholar at Eton in
the year that the great plague raged, all
the boys smoked in school by order, and that
he was never whipped so much in his life as
he was one morning for not smoking.
It was long afterwards a tradition that none
who kept a tobacconist shop in London had
the plague.
(If you think that’s weird, how about the
time when people commonly blew smoke up a
person’s arse to save them from drowning,
including equipment for the procedure hung
along major waterways like the River Thames,
much like AEDs are today.)
Other more sensible preventative measures
included cleaning money in vinegar before
handing it to a shopkeeper, not letting those
same shopkeepers touch raw food with their
bare hands and wearing dead toads around your
neck…
(Not to keep being linky, but there was also
a time when putting frogs in milk was used
as a way to preserve it, sans refrigeration.
Be glad you live in the 21st century!)
Another thing that Londoners believed helped
spread the plague was the many stray cats
and dogs that roamed London’s streets; so
much so that an official edict from King Charles
II stated that “no Swine, Dogs, Cats or
tame Pigeons be permitted to pass up and down
in
Streets, or from house to house, in places
Infected.”
As a result, many thousands of these animals
were killed and promptly buried or burned.
While in some sense they weren’t exactly
wrong on this one (the dogs and cats carried
fleas that may or may not have been previously
infected with the offending microbes), this
nonetheless is generally thought to have had
a net effect of helping the plague’s staying
power as the stray cats and dogs formerly
helped keep the more worrisome rat population
somewhat in check.
Perhaps the most extreme thing Londoners did
back then to help curb the spread of the disease
was quarantine any house that had been host
to a plague victim by sealing it shut for
40 days.
The doors to these houses would be locked
and then marked with a huge red cross, above
which the words “Lord have mercy upon us”
would be scrawled.
To ensure that nobody escaped, a guard would
also often be posted outside.
Since it was common to seal a house with all
of the occupants still inside, regardless
of whether they were sick, many Londoners
took to bribing the guards tasked with searching
homes for signs of the plague to ignore any
such signs in their home, which is one of
the reasons records from that era are so lax.
When this didn’t work, some resorted to
fleeing their homes and all their possessions
before their house could be sealed, choosing
to risk living on the street rather than succumb
to plague or starve to death locked away.
Even when a house was bolted shut and placed
under the watch of a burly guard, there were
still a number of escape options available
to an enterprising occupant.
One of the more popular and straightforward
escape methods was to simply convince the
guard to temporarily leave his post, usually
via a bribe.
Some of the more clandestine escape methods
from the time included tunnelling to freedom,
enlisting the help of friends to poison or
drug the guards and stealthily making a daring
rooftop escape at night like a plague-ridden
ninja.
Other, less subtle, methods of escape included
punching through the thinnest walls of the
property to the outside world or setting fire
to the building and escaping in the confusion.
In at least one case, a man used a makeshift
explosive crafted from fireworks to blow up
his front door as he and his entire family
leapt from a first story window to escape
at the same time.
It turns out, going out the window wasn’t
necessary though.
The blast had killed the guard.
Arguably the most ingenious method of escape
was to, essentially, go fishing for guards.
In this method, the occupants of the home
would carefully lower a noose from windows
to settle around the necks of the guards outside
their homes and either drag them upwards to
their death, or just choke them until they
surrendered their keys.
In the event of the former, the guard’s
body would then be discretely disposed of
by wrapping it in a sheet (thereby disguising
it as the body of a plague victim which nobody
would check very closely) and dumping it unceremoniously
into a passing dead-cart.
Amazingly, it’s noted that at least “a
score” of guards (about 20 to you and me)
were killed in this way by desperate citizens.
Luckily for both citizens and guards, the
worst of the plague passed by the fall of
1666 and absolutely nothing terrible happened
to London ever again…
Unless you want to count the huge fire that
tore through the city just a year later, destroying
approximately 85% of the walled area of the
city, leaving about 65,000 people homeless,
and destroying an awful lot of records concerning
the recent plague, making it difficult to
nail down things like the exact death toll
and how many people were infected but ultimately
recovered.
Then, of course, there were all the other
times horrible things happened in London throughout
its very eventful history.
But who’s counting?